ثم اشرت الى القائد جاك شيراك جاك شيراك
كان له ميزه الاستمراريه السياسيه فهو كان
رئيس وزاره مرتين وخلال 20 عاما كان عمده
باريس وعام 95 انتخب رئيس الجمهوريه وعيد
انتخابات عام 2002 وكان لديه
معارف كقائد الرئيس شراء كان لديه هذه
العلاقات التي سمحت له بان يفهم الاوضاع
وان يدخل في تفكير غالبيه شركاء على قدمي
المساواه وكان يركز او يهتم كثير بارائهم
اذكر بان رئيس شراكه ارسلني مرارا
للالتقاء بالملك عبد الله في المملكه
العربيه السعوديه
للاسترشاد برايه بشان قضايا بعينها واعتقد
ان هذا بالنسبه لتوازن في العالم
والاستقرار كان عاملا بالغا الاهميه وهذا
يذكرنا في الحقيقه برئيس اخر رئيس فرنسي
ربما يضعه البعض في العالم العربي في
الطرف الاخر المقابل للشراك نيكولاسركوزي
عملت معه وانت ايضا هناك الكثير من
الاسئله تتعلق بدوره مثلا في قتل القذافي
وفيما حدث في ليبيا عام 2011
هل من معلومات لديك بشان هذا الموضوع
بس انت محقه الرئيس ركزي كان له نمط مختلف
فهو كان رئيس
شاب لم يعرف الحرب وكان يمثل الجيل الجديد
لسياسي الفرنسي عملت مع رئيس كسفير في
لندن في تلك الحقبه او وقعنا اتفاقات
دفاعيه كبرى مع البريطانيين وكان هذا امرا
جديدا تعلمين ان فرنسا والاتحاد او
المملكه المتحده كان عدوين
وبدات في بدايه القلعه 20 علاقه تفاهم
واستطعنا التعاون في الحربين
وبفضل رئيس سركوزي انتقلنا الى مرحله
اضافيه كنت سفيرا للرئيسى ايضا في المانيا
خلال الازمه الماليه واعتقد انه بالنسبه
لانقاذ منطقه اليورو في وقت كانت اليونان
مهدده جدا لعب ساكوزي دورا كبيرا